Okay, welcome to another Zoom call. Hopefully, it's a beautiful day in your
area as well. It's very bider to look at the member site for any new
information and news and then all the courses are available to you.
Let's jump right in with questions.
Your doctor counters is in okay to put the six drops in biocided. So this is a biocided liquid
in a little water instead of straight because my husband says it burns. Also,
wanted to know your thoughts about the treatment diet, the macias, earth, or cancer, or Candida.
Thank you. Yeah, you can use the biocided water. That's just, so if you need water,
put it in your drink or him, that's just fine. So that's good. Diotomatious earth that can be good for
things in your gut. I would just suggest that you go slow. A lot of, a lot of things I like
you'll hear that you're taking a tablespoon of diatomatious earth a day. Don't ever start with that,
start with a half a teaspoon and work your way up. So just start with every you're starting to
do a new supplement, something like that. It isn't really technically a supplement. It's tried
to bind stuff in the gut. Help kill some parasites in the gut and things that you want to just start
slow. And then I wouldn't that be something that does not take, you know, constantly. It's not
something you take on a daily basis for the rest of your life. You take that for a period of time,
you can go off and put for a period of time. So yes, it's okay to put the biocided in water
or in your drink. Diatomatious earth is spied. It's not really a cancer killer,
but it helps kill some things in the gut. But you just start with a low dose.
What's the difference between the clear hiss or natural clear hiss and the clear histamine scavenger?
So when you're dealing with histamine issues, you have to experiment a little bit with
supplements to pull histamines out of your body because there's a lot of different nutritional
anti-inflammatories to help pull histamines. The standards that are out there are the
quercetin and some other things that's in the clear hiss. I think the clear hiss has like
more different ingredients. The histamine scavenger is just a totally different product. It has more
and types of nutrients in there. Some people do just so much better of the histamine scavenger
and the clear hiss doesn't do anything for them. And some people do really well in the clear
hiss and not the histamine scavenger doesn't do anything for them. So you just have to experiment.
Now these two are completely different than another product out there called the hista clear.
So the hista clear is completely different. That is a DAO enzyme. So the DAO enzyme is produced
in your tissues through the H-A-M-T-D. And it's produced in your gut through the DAO H-D-A-O gene.
And defects in either one of those genes is going to produce less of that. So the DAO enzyme
is what clears histamine, what breaks down histamine in your tissues and in the gut.
Well you can take the DAO enzyme straight. That's what hista clear is. It's kind of expensive.
It comes to like a dollar a pill. But it doesn't absorb. So it'll only work in the gut. So if your
problem is a lot of histamine in the gut or you have huge histamine problems because of dietary histamines
then you use hista clear when you're eating foods or when you're trying to calm down the inflammation
of the gut. H hista clear will not pull histamines out of the tissues. So clear hist,
natural clear hist, it's also and clear histamine scavenger pulls histamine out of the tissues.
Those are just different types of products that you're going to have to experiment with. So
you have to try. If you're been using the clear histid it's like it's not really working.
Just try the histamine scavenger and see if that works better for you.
Also about a lower no histamine diet. Should I be taking the aloevia immune aloe supplement?
I think it is a histamine inducer but I'm not sure. No, the aloevia immune is not a histamine inducer.
So you're fine taking that supplement. So there's no negatives about taking the aloevia immune.
It's not going to produce any more histamine. What will produce histamine in the gut is food sensitivities.
So what will produce histamine? So histamine is an initial immune inducer when there is
some some antigen that's present. So if there's an antigen that's present, your body will make histamine.
So let's say pollen in the air, you breathe it in, it's irritating the tissue, it's inducing what's
called a cytokine reaction and it's going to produce a histamine reaction. Then histamine and these
inducible what are called immune inducible cytokines, stimulated immune response against that
pathogen. Well of course pollen can't be killed so you just produce histamine. Now normal people,
why don't I don't react to the pollen in the air? Because they don't have issues with it mainly
because of genetic reasons. So people that have asthma have typically a lot of H&MT defects and
other histamine clearing gene defects. You've seen a lot of them on your genetic profile.
So people that have a lot of defects are that they don't clear histamine like someone who doesn't
have those defects and then they don't have issues with pollen and such. So they need to support
that somehow. Now from a medical standpoint, they're just on a histamine drug. But if you're trying
to stay away from any histamine drugs and their side effects, you're taking these types of products.
So these are the clear hist and the histamine scavenger. Now if you're getting a lot of inflammation
in the gut with things that you're eating, then you use the histamine clear. But you don't just jump
to that too. We want to find out why is there something that's inducing histamine in the gut and
almost always inducing histamines are if you have antibodies to different food proteins
or peptides, harsh parts of proteins. So if antibodies to food peptides and proteins, every time
you eat that, you're going to produce this histamine reaction, this inflammatory reaction. You end up
with this huge inflammatory gut issue. It also affects your brain the same way. So testing food antibodies
can be helpful. And how would you test that? You test that with Syrex testing. And there's a whole
bunch of information on Syrex 2, Syrex 3x and Syrex 10. That's Syrex array 2, 3x and 10. A whole bunch
of information on that in the chronic disease and autoimmune course. But if you're having those kind
of gut issues, it's good to test for that. Remember when I'm testing you for food, I'm testing only
for cancer drivers. I'm not testing for food sensitivities. The only way to test for food sensitivities
is to do a blood test CPM antibodies to different food peptides. Your doctor colors, I have not been
giving my husband the femenazole for a while since he eliminated the shakes. So I decided to put it
in his formula with the rest of the items. However, I have been giving it every day for the last week.
Should I continue every day? Tell retested or do three days on four days off. I would give it a
break maybe go five days on and go off the weekends. That would keep it simple for you.
And then we can recheck and also want to know how he's doing with other objective and subjective
findings too. Thank you for my Kandita return. Would apple cider vinegar help on a daily basis?
So I know apple cider vinegar is a hot thing to take in the nutritional world for God to
because it's acidic and it helps your stomach acid pH balance. But to me, I've said this lots
of different times. To me, it just makes absolutely no sense. The acid that is in
apple cider vinegar is acetic acid. The acid that's in your stomach is hydrochloric acid. Why don't you
just take hydrochloric acid tablets? It's far less expensive than buying a bottle of apple cider
vinegar and taking a tablespoon of that with your food. So it's to me taking a bottle of HCL is far
less expensive and you're getting the correct type of acid that your stomach actually produces.
So the reason why you take apple cider vinegar is to increase the acidity of your stomach to help
with digestion because our stomachs can become very pH alkaline. And this is another reason why you would
use alkaline water because your pH or your stomach has to be about 2.0 to 2.5 and you're alkalizing
your stomach acid so you're decreasing your stomach's ability to digest food which makes absolutely
no sense to me whatsoever. So some of the gimmicks that you hear in the natural world aren't really
wrong physiology. So to me it's just you know you got to balance it out with wisdom and knowledge
and physiology and it has to be just things have to make sense that way. So an apple cider vinegar
makes sense because you're adding an acid to your gut but it's not the same acid as your stomach. It
will help a person but to me why spend the extra money in apple cider vinegar or just do HCL?
Are you familiar with the two feathers healing formula? Yes the two other feathers healing formula
I had some a long time ago I don't have any now to my knowledge it's very similar to the black
tab. It's a topical formula and yeah it can be really great and we've had multiple patients that
have used it with success. Watching Thomas sigfreed's video on YouTube he has proof that cancer is
not a genetic disease. Well he doesn't have the proof that cancer is not a genetic disease it's been
known forever that cancer is not a genetic disease. Now understand there are some genetic
imponents to certain types of cancer so but you know so for instance anybody here has had colon cancer
most likely you've been screened for this certain gene. Well well maybe not if you have no history
of colon cancer you're failing but if you have a history of colon cancer you're failing I'll guarantee
you they screen you for this gene because there can be a genetic predisposition to colon cancer
with a certain type of gene you have a couple patients that have that. So yeah cancer is not a
genetic disease it is an acquired disease that it's environmental. He wrote a book on as cancer
as a metabolic disease and I read that book that came out I don't know five seven eight ten years ago
he's not a doctor but his studies suggest that cancer spread by glucose. Well the only thing I did
like about his book is that he he's not a practicing physician so matter of fact his whole idea
to starve cancer was everybody with cancer should go on a ketogenic diet and he had one one patient
example in the book who actually had smoldering blood cancer not a hard cancer so it was
was not even a good example for a ketogenic diet and this person did well and stated remission
on a ketogenic diet now so the reason what I write about is that every cancer is different and every
person's different so he makes these dogmatic statements that I didn't like in his book I mean
there's things to learn from everybody so I do try to glean the truth out of everything that's
out there and he had a lot of good studies and he had a lot of good work and his books I'm not
knocking his book but then when you take it to the point that every single person with cancer should
be on a ketogenic diet and it's always this and this is what it is then it starts to go oh it's just
a little fishy it's like every person if somebody got helped with chemo that every single person should
be on chemo that just doesn't make any sense every human being is different so that's why we test for
was your cancer mainly driven by glucose as your cancer mainly driven by glutamine that's why we
do test that one h i f one a gene because if you have that gene defect you have a much greater chance
of your cancer being driven by glucose and doing a ketogenic diet or a keto like diet or
restricted fasting or restricted eating modified fasting can be really good for you
so that's that's why we test the specific foods you endorse two solas which one would you recommend
here's another one for that was recommended on on amazons and this is much less expensive so this
sola is I looked it up on amazon it's like 560 bucks or something like that I don't know I can't
vouch for that sauna I have one of the two that that we sell on our site I really like it the
what I've heard from other people having these less expensive solas is that they take longer to
heat up now if that's not an issue for you if you can zip up your sauna and sit there longer or you
can turn it on and unzip it and climb in while you're going to lose the heat the time you zip it up
you're going to so you're just going to it's going to take longer most likely now I personally do not
buy all the hype about the whether it's an infrared far infrared sauna near infrared sauna or it's
using far and near infrared and the reason why I don't buy that hype with any of the solas that are
on the market any of the solas that are on the market is because none of them are true
far infrared so we have that infrared heating device that's called hyperthermia and we have
that for sale in our store and there's probably a dozen of our patients that have it maybe some of
you that are on this call have the have our far infrared hyperthermia machine now there's a
reason why it's five thousand dollars and it's the plate is only about six by ten inches around that
because that's how much it claims to make a true far infrared device these solas that are sold
for a thousand dollars even these wooden ones you're just paying for the wood that are sold for five
thousand dollars and they say they have an infrared heat device that they show a picture and it's
it's red you know the amount of in true infrared that's coming off of there is minuscule so they're
using the studies that are out there on something like our hyperthermia machine and equating that to
well because they have one percent true infrared coming out of their sauna apparatus is that it's a
true infrared sauna well it's just not there's just not legal standards to this so really I've said
you know forever that the real purpose of the sauna is to get you to sweat so if the five hundred
sixty dollar sauna can get you to sweat it's a complicated purpose so by all means I would go for
the less expensive one the only thing that you have to be careful of is that you just have to know that
it might take 20 minutes to heat up and you just have to be okay with that so that's all I've
heard from other people that have used less expensive solas and you have to be able to sweat if
your sauna is not getting you to sweat it's not to publish it it's purpose whole idea of the sauna
is to get you to sweat so that you're detoxing through your pores and taking some pressure off of
your liver detox pathways that's the whole idea of the sauna now these sauna companies will give you
all this hype about our infrared infrared mixed infrared all this stuff it's a bunch of below because
there's really truly not enough infrared in any of these sodas to give you any health benefits that
they're claiming off the infrared piece so just know that reviewing my most recent blood lab
results and aware that I do coffee animals by VA oncologist was concerned about the low calcium
and low sodium levels and stated that coffee animals can cause electrolyte disturbances
well in all due respect she's wrong coffee animals are not going to cause electrolyte disturbances
if you had chronic diarrhea you could have electrolyte disturbances but not doing the coffee
animals so that's not it now your low calcium and low sodium levels can be easily corrected by adding
some calcium and sodium it's really the concern with a cancer patient is elevated calcium
so when I saw your blood work with low calcium it's like a word about that it's the elevated calcium
that you worry about with cancer because elevated cancer elevated calcium is suggestive
metastatic destructive disease so metastasis to bowl with bony destruction so when you have low calcium
I'm not so concerned about that you could easily supplement for that so the benefits of coffee
animals even if they were disturbing your electrolytes it's pretty easy to take some electrolytes
the other benefits to the coffee animals is stimulating your carousel the sparrows of
genetics far out right way even if this person was correct about his electrolyte disturbance
I'm wondering about some random symptoms and weather they could be related in pointy to system
systematic secondary infection or her balance
I last week zoom I inquired about red streaks first noticed in January 2023 and my legs and torso
the cow would go blasted only a few hours at a time you mentioned the possibility of live disease
I have not gone through your live course but by symptoms and photos are light it doesn't match well
a description of a limb and gytus which which can be true too you can have inflammation of different
things too kind of fit so that that may be true so you could diagnostic picture of that when
we helpful though I have no open wood streaks tend to go toward away from my groin and armpits
I do have swollen lymph nodes also so swollen lymph nodes also could talk about
possibility of infection as well also in the last week I've had trouble with urination with urgency
of urination there's not the pressure of a full-blown uti but my first need to go is desperate
I would want to know I don't know who does it ask this question I'd want to know your
age as we age you know you might have had a history of you know utis once or twice or five times
in the past as we age we tend to lose a lot of those symptoms of uti and the only symptom that we
have is urgency and that as we get a little older we can almost get a little delirious and that is
your first side you're over 65 and you have a little urgency and a little kind of cloudy thinking
and people are like are you okay you have to think of uti and many times you will get any uti
symptoms even if you have history of uti so you know what those symptoms are if you have a first
need to go and it's desperate like oh my gosh you're going to run to the bathroom pretty good chance
you have a uti you know you can you know you guys you can go buy an Amazon a urinary test trip kit
and it comes with like 50 little dipsticks and you just go pee in a cup and you can test it yourself
and see if there's any bacteria in there at least so that's what they would do in a doctor's office
of the charge of 50 bucks you can buy the whole kit for 50 bucks and it gives you 50 strips so that's
something you can get you can just buy those on Amazon now if you have a uti most likely we'll see
bacteria in your urine but you also want to get a cbc so complete blood test a cbc complete blood
count will give you white white blood cell count and you'll have a slightly elevated white blood cell
if you have an infection as well also if you're thinking you have an infection outside of the
urinary tract you won't see it on a urinary dipstick um typically you wouldn't get swollen lip
dealt with a uti but anything is possible if you have any inflammation of your lip system
of your masculitis or something like that that's a concern as well but you would see that on a cbc
you'll see an elevated white blood cell count I've been doing coffee animals every day since December
could uh less than high-ede animal provoke a uti no so unless you're putting it in the wrong place
so no that that if you you should watch you should be watching your animal uh tube out well
just soap and water and rinsing it really good you'll be fine with that so um it just your that
just wouldn't work that way and I've had a perpetual earache and sore throat since the fall of 2021
okay well we really should I mean I don't I don't know if you've had recent blood work or not
um hold on one second because I just added a um I just added a test to our Rupa store um and I wanted
to get the name of it and tell you uh so stick with me um searching our Rupa store right now
why isn't it showing me that I have to do it again um but I just added what's called what I named
a simple cbc and cmp and it's like 50 bucks so it just keeps it less expensive for you to get a simple
cbc and a complete metabolic panel or inexpensive it's not showing on the Rupa store
right now so I have to redo it I don't think it's saved my changes um so it's simple to get that
test if your doctor won't do it or you under your insurance I was diagnosed with Hashimoto's 20 years
ago I have not been very symptomatic since for hair loss which increased a few years ago now the last
week or two hair losses become extreme so things that will layer your Hashimoto so if you still have
antibodies um thyroglobulin antibodies or TPO antibodies you still have Hashimoto's
typically those don't go away sometimes they can go into remission and you can be fine for a very
long time and then they can flare up again what can flare your autoimmune disease well the truth is
anything anything can flare your autoimmune disease I do give oh I have several videos in
um I think it's sections or module 7 of the autoimmune course is solely on Hashimoto's it's all
the latest information on Hashimoto's you could look up some videos on there and I do have some
videos on what can flare an autoimmune disease do latest research the last couple of years I'll tell
you salt can be a huge flare so if you're salty in your food iodine can be a huge flare of Hashimoto's
so if you're taking iodine you want to cut that out but I have a list of a whole much
heavy literally a whole anything can flare your your autoimmune disease might any of these be related
or pointed to an infection I would definitely get a CBC to make sure you don't have any infection
and send me the results of that so yep run a CBC you test everyone for whether IP-6 will help or not
yep that's sort of our standard things we test for do you have thoughts on ozone especially
home ozone units for daily rectal ozone so daily rectal ozone insulation can be really can be
really good for a lot of things you will absorb some of that ozone and the ozone of your system can
be beneficial for a lot of things now in you know we've had this discussion you know 50 times on
the zoom call I know this is probably a new person I see this question to me ozone makes no sense
what you're trying to kill a pathogen not what you're trying to kill cancer so the ozone is
O3 so that's what ozone is so just understand the chemistry so ozone so oxygen is is O2 that's
oxygen it's a stable molecule oxygen it's two um electrons and so it's stable when it's connected
to each other like that ozone is O3 it's an unstable molecule and because it's unstable we can use
it to it's to our benefit so it will search for something to attach to it attaches to pathogens
that's what ozone really in our environment when you go out after a thunderstorm and you smell
ozone and it smells so nice and fresh really that is God's way of cleaning the atmosphere so ozone is
produced with with with um light need so a light need produces ozone the rain can pull ozone down
from the ozone layer and it kills pathogens it helps kill mold in our environment in the environment
of the world that you're walking in it can be very beneficial for you you could use an ozone
machine um in the air to help kill mold in your house you can kill mold underneath your blankets you
can kill mold in a closet by putting the ozone machine in a closet I recommend people put an
ozone machine in a musty but in a musty basement I have an ozone machine in our office I have an
ozone machine in our house my kids have ozone machines now too much ozone can be damaging to
the lung tissue so all these machines have a setting on it so it won't produce too much ozone so
there are some machines out there that don't have that setting they're commercial use ozone machines
and you do it to be more careful with them because you could damage your lungs with too much ozone
now doing ozone the way this person is saying and using rectal ozone and using iv ozone well what
would that be used for it kills pathogens so if you have Lyme disease if you have chronic mold
ozone can be beneficial for that uh ozone will stimulate an inflammatory reaction too so you
could actually inject ozone into a degenerative knee and that can be beneficial for that but to kill
cancer with ozone I just don't know about that there's just not any data that shows that it's gonna kill
a cancer cell it doesn't kill your living cells I don't know how the mechanism how it's gonna kill
your cancer cell so it's you know adding an oxygen reactive oxygen species to the tissue can
actually cause cancer so using too much ozone internally that you won't absorb ozone if you're
just breathing it ozone from an ozone machine so you're not getting internal O3 that's breaking apart
it's um and giving it a reactive oxygen species so a reactive oxygen species is um
is cancer causing that is that is an oxidative reaction that can cause cancer so um there's
differences between an oxidative reaction an oxygen so oxygen um so a reactive oxygen species
ROS is damaging to your cells so I I don't see the benefit of using ozone personally and I'm not
against somebody who feels like really you do ozone to kill cancer and they feel like they've
got results from that so I'm not making a judge we'll call that way I'm just giving you my opinion
yeah I see ozone used I see the successive ozone used um from a clinical standpoint if you're trying
to kill pathogens I'm currently doing a month of focused naturopathic cancer therapies five days a
week nine to four such as IV vitamin C with ozone there you go again uh H bot inference on us
beamer which is p-e-m-f that's a low um gauze p-e-m-f rife and attempting to get more
consistent into ketosis um while taking supplements and weekend coffee animals after having a full
body MRI in January I'm sensing it's time to get a pet skin when I return to the cities in order
to see what is active versus dormant so first I want to make comment about doing this you're doing all
these things these are great and these can really help with detoxification pathways and all that kind
of stuff after doing a full body MRI in January since you get a pet scanner returned to the cities in
order to see what is active versus dormant I had intended to get one back in December but decided
against it however more of a full have a bottle of supplement you recommended to help get rid of
the radioactive stuff i think you're talking about the folio path someone else suggested getting
chelation IV immediately following a pet scan any thoughts or um on the chelation IV um chelation IV
where I think that is beneficial as if you have acute heavy metal toxicity like you're exposed to
arsenic um or aluminum or mercury um chelation IV has a lot of downsides so you're putting a heavy
key later right into your blood vessels to pull stuff out of the tissue I mean right away you have to
your your bells and whistles should go off because you are going to be pulling stuff out of the tissue
way faster than your liver phase one phase two phase three pathways are going to be able to get rid of it
and all you're going to do is circulate around your body now in a crisis mode where this person has
been exposed to a high amount of heavy metals and they're poisoned that's where you just got to do it
but in a situation like this no I would not say doing you know radiation the amount of radiation that's
in a pet scan it's not worth IV chelation therapy you could make yourself a lot sicker by doing that
what do you know about Sandra Rose Michael who developed EES and do you think EES as a what do you think
of it as a christian how is it same or different than rife are there any benefits from this I searched
our member site didn't come up with anything there yeah because I I'm not familiar with it I did look
it up and I'm just not I'm not I can't really comment on it because I'm not familiar enough with it
I don't know if it's a machine that they're using or it's a technique that they're using um I just don't
I just don't know enough so I want to give you this information okay just got my results back
from the cheek swab you suggested taking a roller clear is it okay for me to take it
and I'm on an astrosol which is a horrible block yes yeah you can take that right along with it
I struggled to enter the zoom questions this week my question would show sent each time I tried
a second question it would be really that's okay we did get your question about three times that's
all right um I'm not I'm never but on that side to see what it says but yeah we did get it if you
if you you know it's no harm if we got it twice so can you explain the benefits of clear PC so clear
PC is is a PC stands for phyto cannabinoid so what is a phyto cannabinoid it's CBD so what's the
benefits of CBD oh my gosh oh much time do we have CBD has huge benefits just like any other nutrient
so you have endocannabinoid receptors on every cell membrane and it it can decrease inflammation
it can help calm it can decrease glutamates it if there's just tons and tons of benefits of CBD
so in one sense it can be a cancer killer so CBD is different than THC THC is typically from
marijuana and it's gonna be it's gives you totally different effect CBD is typically from hemp
um nothing everything we sell is hemp derived CBD pretty much everything on the market is hemp
derived CBD as it's there's just so much more CBD and hemp than there is in marijuana it's so
much cheaper to grow and it's legal so Avabar graduate has but added to my protocol I see that it is
fermented for my diet no fermented foods were redirected yeah but this isn't tried fermented
wheat germ oil and it's a cancer killer so definitely this is something you need to take
the one who wrote about urination urgency is 54 so again I would definitely get a CBC done for sure
so would you recommend D-bannos for UTI symptoms yes so you're there's really not any downside for
D-bannos it's something you get you wouldn't necessarily take all the time you take it only
based upon symptoms you take it like a medication then have feel like you have a UTI then you take that
also I didn't mention you guys are probably aren't you doing that but make sure you're running your
rife program for UTI and things like that if you are suspecting anything so there's a bunch of
urinary tract infection programs and different bacterium programs and different viral programs and
colvin programs so make sure you're looking through your rife because you can use those use your rife
that should be your first go to since the coffee can take a very an amount of time to be ingested
at which time the 15 minute timer should start might the toxins get reabsorbed if it goes too long
same with the detox foot bath so I think you're talking about doing a coffee enema
for longer than 15 minutes I'm not sure I'm understanding your question
completely so so if you're doing a coffee enema and it's taking more than 15 minutes no so coffee
enema is stimulating the vagus nerve down at the rectal area and that are by stimulating
phase one phase two pathway in your liver also stimulating your parasympathetic stimulates your
immune system so it's not I would worry about reabsorbing toxins if you're doing everything else that
you should be doing to it you're having good bowel goods do you suggest that all this test remind me
what the all this test is like a blank here oh that's the anti-bolignant test
why I you know I'm not as I'm not familiar enough with that test to say to use that we've never
used that test I've never done any research on that test so I don't know if that would be a good
test we typically recommend people to get two remarkers run now they're stuck if they don't show any
two remarkers so they can't use two remarkers to kind of guide you know whether they're doing better
or not but even if you're a two remarker tests are all with the normal limits you still can
use those as a marker their markers so like any blood test as a marker tells you that
something might go might be going on and then you do further diagnostic testing to see what that
something might be your markers are inexpensive I think are if you build two remarker profiles
on like a hundred bucks it's it's something that you could do on a monthly basis most people
it's also covered by insurance if your doctor recommends it and and orders the test to
standard tests I have tenitis and been taking an E300 I know there's a rife program but it's
eight hours should I just run a couple hours during the day will it help if I never get through the
entire program of course I'm running my cancer programs yeah so if there's a program that you
want to run on the rife that's too long it just running any time on that program can be helpful
tenitis is a difficult thing to treat now I recommend the Delta toco treat all that's what say
the anano e300 or our apop e is the same thing um but tenitis is uh so remember the
ears are certain parts of your body that you have what are called terminal vascularization meaning
that you don't have an asthmocene vessels meaning that you don't have other vessels that feed the
area if a vessel gets constricted or blocked so in your heart you have terminal vessels in your
ear you have terminal vessels and the your vascularization can be affected by a lot of different things
infection by lower eye, Lyme disease, heavy metal toxicity, sympathetic overdrive, your sympathetic
nervous system causes constriction of the vessels that's what increases your blood pressure
and that can lead to a lack of oxygen to the the auditory nerve so the auditory nerve in your ear is
integrated by goes back to the temporal lobe so if you have damage of the nerve back to the
temporal lobe the chance of that regrow it is very very difficult now the benefit of taking Delta
toco treat all for tenitis or for your heart is because it helps open up those terminal vessels
so i've had people with tenitis that have started with Delta toco treat all and they literally
cured their tenitis i've had people with complete loss of hearing in one ear and i put them on
the Delta toco treat all which is the inner part of the vitamin E molecule and they got their
hearing back completely so but i've also had people with tenitis that i just couldn't budge
ever never did it seem like no matter what we did it didn't help nothing helped i do know that you
have to look for inflammatory other causes of inflammation what tonight is to so you do getting a
Syrix array ten can be helpful for that but again there's some people if you have damage all the way
back to the temporal lobe it's pretty hard to fix that now there are some temporal lobe
brain-based therapy exercises that you can do and my wife actually has today to suggest we
to put some of those things together so when i do i will actually post it up on our member site
where everybody around create a blonde post about it have you ever heard of Ralph boss's top five
nutritious chemicals for cancer, respiratory, and flabinones, curcumin, cell porofanes, and EGCG
um yeah actually interviewed Ralph on a one of my podcasts a couple of years ago
so all of these things are good so all these things i talk about on on least every other zoom call
because these are all flabinones that are anti-inflammatory so these are so good for not just cancer
for everybody but you have to remember with these things especially your esveratrol
esveratrol has the shortest half-life and just about any nutrient that you could consume so you have
to break it up into doses and it's sometimes hard for you to do it's hard for me to do um maybe it's
easy for you because you're more disciplined to take your supplements morning, doing it nighttime but
sometimes the esveratrol won't uh above anything else you've got to break it up throughout the day
and also remember EGCG which is the catechin from green t-extract is the most polluted nutrient
the market period exclamation point all green t-extract all of it all EGCG comes from China
so you have to have a really good clean source of EGCG
um and if you went body GCG green t-extract at you know at any store out there you're going to get
just crap stopped that's polluted um my favorite is the is the tv go from US enzymes because they are
anal cue about their purity so are some other good companies they're really anal about their
purity they check it and they just they buy only from good clean sources so can i eat flaks instead of
the soy isle flaminones yes you can you don't want the soy uh flax seed but there's other flaminnoids
in other things so corsetin is another good one too too much flax is going to be too much omega-6
remember that too so you want to keep a good omega-3 to omega-6 to omega-9 balance those are your facts
that you're consuming and too much flax seed is going to be very high in omega-6 which is going to be
pro-inflammatory so that's what the benefit of olive oil it's an omega-9 it's an anti-inflammatory
omega-3's fish oil are also anti-inflammatory be it on a hormone blockers is there any blood
work or other tests i should ask my oncology for support to keep an eye on
well no not really um if you want to know your hormone level the best test to do is the
Dutch test d-u-t-c-h and you can order that through loop of labs but you really don't need to run it
because you're if you're an hormone blocker if you're bad estrogen you're all your estrogen
it's going to be in the cellar so there's no need to spend the money on that test
would run that test somebody who just followed up they have cancer or and their doctor was to put
them on hormone blockers and they don't want to go on it they want to look at their hormone levels
i just ran a test for somebody and this went over with them two days ago and her
um uh bad estrogen her 400-oxy esterone was elevated not good even though her E1-E2-E3
those are your standard estergins were actually the low normal uh for some reason most likely a
cytokrome P450 pathway was pushing it to be converted to the bad estrogen which can drive
cancers hormone related cancers i'm having one VM in the AM
good consistency and sometimes another later in the day i do coffee animal every day sometimes
morning sometimes PM the only day i'd say be careful with PM is it might keep you up if you're
absorbing any of the caffeine if it's not then don't worry about it going through your detox course
more than one VM is preferred if you're having one good VM you feel like you're cleaning it out
maybe an extra one during the day i think you're just fine uh should i be getting some magnesium
no i wouldn't i wouldn't so it really depends if you feel like you're really cleaning your
your gut out and it's not like i had a bowel movement but i just feel like i have more in there
and i'm not really cleaning myself out then yeah go on some magnesium um to help you but if you feel
like you're cleaning out and sometimes you're having two uh when you're doing a coffee animal you're
not having to expel any with that or very little then i'd say no to worry about that i lead
over the center console in my car last week and hurt a rib it's quite a lot but i think it's
and i think it's broken is that this is new for me concerns um yeah i mean we even if you don't have
cancer you can break a rib um i can't tell you how many ribs i broke i mean i broke
every figure in each hand um some more than once and broken you know ankles and um and uh
fibula's and so this has nothing to do with pathological fractures and nothing to do with
metastasis to the bone you could break a rib doing something like that you could sprain a rib
doing something like that and it could hurt just as bad and take longer to heal than a fractured rib
but always you do want to consider you know is it a pat do i have a pathological fracture
um get an x-ray yeah well that's not very much radiation if you have a car fracture that could
take an x-ray for you um you can see if if there's a break there really there's nothing you can do
for the broken rib itself so if you didn't have cancer i would tell you not to go get an x-ray
because there's not a whole lot you can do for it except maybe use a rib belt to just let it heal
the problem is every time you breathe you're in a coastal muscles move that rib at a cause of your
irritation so ribs take a long time to heal they just do sprain or fracture when you have cancer and
you it's something seemed to crack easily and you're concerned about it then you're concerned about
do i have metastasis to the bone causing a weakness in that bone um and so that's when you might want
to do an x-ray to see if there's a fracture because then you that might spark you to go and look if there's
any metastasis to that bone um and why would you need to know that well because it might spark you to
look at any other possible bony metastasis it might spark you to do some other form of treatment
like radiation um to a metastatic tumor to the bone because that's always going to be
litigants always going to be bony destructive um but if you're like hey i'm not doing that anyhow
then then um then don't do that you know i've had people that hurt something and then it's like well
i can live with this but should i look at it and you know sometimes it's like well maybe it's god
way of showing you that there is metastasis there so you can take care of it so you don't want to just
quote a quote bad up on everything and suffer it through something just pray about that whether this is
whether god's trying to show you something or heck you know there's times you fall down and maybe
it's just me but times i fall down and hurt myself and it's just because i'm clumsy or it's a work
into art so it doesn't mean you bounce trying to always tell you something it's sometimes you just
try to tell you to use things at least for me sometimes just tell me uh slow down so
is that pragovo scan used acceptable in conventional care? well slowly becoming accepted but not
very quickly it's not paid for by insurance still um so yeah you know it takes a long time for
standards of care to catch up with anything new but unfortunately standards of care are getting
worse i mean people are like okay i wait till they start covering alternative care uh yeah
that till we have completely you know change in you know it's never gonna happen so maybe in the new
habit in the new earth then you'll have average but i think it says that we're going to be healed by
the leaves of the trees and the plants that we eat so we're not going to need have a need for that
so sorry i digress no i don't think it's really accepted by conventional care there may be some
conventional doctors that are recommended but they would probably be in private practice because
they would get fired if they recommended something outside of their system that's the way we that's
where we are with conventional care doctors are doctors anymore they're they're basically um
technicians so you know they just do they do they you know what they're supposed to recommend they
keep sick outside in the box they can't think outside the system or they will get in trouble so
the doctors are controlled by the hospital system so yes a pruduvo is an MRI so it's
big denic resident imaging and it does not use contrast dye so that's the benefit of the pruduvo
there's no contrast dye used you know any catalyticium and it's uh it is MRI so there's no radiation
all right i think we'll end for the day thank you guys for being on
and um well then i'm praying for you guys daily um i've been told that the MRI is the most harmful
of them all i don't know who told you that but i would disagree with that
MRI doesn't give you any radiation CT scan is probably the most harmful between CT
test scan and MRI so CT scan gives you about the same rad dose of radiation is 50 chest x-rays
so of all the x-rays the chest x-ray is the most radiation of any x-ray and one CT scan is about 50
chest x-rays rad dose there's no radiation in MRI but if you have catalyticium toxicity well that
could be really bad but you don't know if you have catalyticium toxicity unless you
are exposed to catalyticium so some people but it's very very small and it's less than one percent
of the people i've ever gotten MRI got really sick with catalytic toxicity and if you got 10 MRIs
you could end up with over exposure to catalyticium but you don't necessarily have a catalytic
sensitivity all right i will see you guys next week bye bye